le tout ball et le kin ball de nom
étrange pour des sports de balle plutôt
simple expérimenté pendant les vacances
à magny les hameaux
pourtant si les jeunes manica sont
séduits reste que les règles ne sont pas
encore tout à fait assimiler qu'est ce
que c'est le patron
c'est une balle qu'on lance alors une
sorte de trampoline et qui ont la fin
d'exercice et fallait c'est une balle
enflammé il fallait passer la pilule le
plus de balles
de leur côté des adversaires le football
vient de suisse et c'est une sorte de
passe à dix améliorer mélangeant
handball volley et squash piles et de se
faire des passes sans que l'adversaire
puisse les intercepter c'est ensuite de
tirer dans la cible il faut que la balle
rebondisse par terre avant que
l'adversaire ne les rattrape et donc il
n'y a pas de cible qui est propre à
chacune des équipes
le kin ball vient du canada c'est ce
sport spectaculaire où les joueurs
peuvent se saisir du ballon avec toutes
les parties du corps
l'idée étant qu'il ne rebondisse pas au
sol coûte que coûte au kin-ball c c'est
alors non on appelle ça en fait
pour ceux qui jouent un peu dans la rue
avant de jouer au dauphin dauphine donc
c'était on envoyait un ballon on
appelait un prénom et on devait le
rattraper ben là c'est un peu le même
principe ça joue par sur trois équipes
composées de quatre joueurs et donc il y
à un protocole pour l'appellation de
l'équipe puis doit aller récupérer le
ballon et donc ce gros ballon qui est
envoyé en l'air doit être récupéré par
un ou plusieurs membres de l'équipe qui
a été appelé avant qu'ils ne tombent par
terre
si cette équipe là n'arrivent pas à le
récupérer c'est les deux autres équipes
qu'il obtienne les qu'en fait les
animateurs de manier la mauve elle
derrière la découverte de ces deux
sports faire passer un message aux
enfants
si bien de tchouk que le king ball sont
des activités sportives ou les enfants
sont jamais mis en contact il n'ya pas
d'insécurité les enfants sont là ça ne
s'est pas livrée à se faire mal en tout
cas et c est non énormément basée sur la
notion de respect et de fair play
en france une trentaine de clubs
proposent la pratique du tout et du
football